mel robbins is one of the most booked
speakers in the world
and an international best-selling author
whose work has been translated into 32
languages
she went from being an unemployed 41
year old facing bankruptcy to impacting
millions of people through her books
speeches and coaching sessions
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best mel robbins
and my take on her top 10 rules for
success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one raise your own game
gotta raise your own game and so what is
the game that you play at work
you gotta get out of the head that it's
all about you the best team members are
always thinking about how to make the
team better
the best team members are loyal to the
team the best
people to work with are the ones that
are in it together
and so in order for you to get your
toxic colleague to shift behavior
you got to model it and here's the
interesting thing about the research
when people are working with co-workers
or on a team
where people collaborate and where you
have honest conversations
it creates what we call psychological
safety which basically just means
i feel safe working with you i know that
if i come to you with feedback you
listen
i know that if i tell you how your
behavior is impacting me
you'll actually care i know that if you
need help you'll come to me and i know
if i need help
i can come to you that's what
psychological safety means you're a safe
person and hopefully a fun person to
work with
so you've gotta model that that means
you gotta ask for support that means you
gotta have direct collabora
or direct conversations and it means you
got to support your team members too
and do you realize that when
you work with other people that do this
team members are 35 times more likely
to show visible commitment to your
success and they're 47
more likely when you model it to work
hard to build and maintain
your trust so don't ever get resigned
and thinking that the way that you
behave
won't impact how somebody else is
behaving around you
rule number two be a realistic optimist
one of the most important things
when you're in a situation where the
truth the facts are
that there is more on your plate than
one human being can effectively handle
on his or her own there's a really
important moment where you have to
surrender
to the chaos that your life is
for the next couple weeks things are
going to change when summer hits
but part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not
the way that i want things to go and so
if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going
on it's gonna make it feel even more
overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it
so i call this and i think sean anchor's
the one that came up with this
this this term realistic
optimism realistic optimism
is a really powerful mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin on
a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life
right now and you are
still maintaining an
optimistic point of view and
what that means is that you when you're
an
optimist you believe that your actions
and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle
what's on your plate you believe that
based on your thoughts and your actions
you can positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent
or terrified because you just got a
scary health diagnosis
or you're spinning because somebody just
told you they don't want to be in a
relationship with you anymore
whatever it is that you're facing that's
making you feel overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be
a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay
very optimistic and positive and know
that everything that you think and do is
in your control
and that when you know that your
behavior matters
it gives you a sense of empowerment
that's proven by research super duper
important
it's also why you can have a very
hard life right now and a very
overwhelming life right now and still be
happy
because you know based on being a
realistic optimist
that this period will pass and you know
that there are things that you can think
about and do that are within your
control
rule number three practice emotional
resilience
often times when you hit bottom you
bounce
and that's where i think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when
you know you feel like nobody loves you
you have the power to learn how to love
yourself
and if there's one thing that covid 19
has done
regardless of whatever devastation it
has caused in your life is it has forced
us all
to experience the great pause
and i read that in a medium article and
i love
that idea of a pause because i think in
2020 our lives have gotten
so fast and so digital
and when you are forced to pause and get
present and to slow down
you are reminded of what's actually
important and what's important is your
health
what's important is your family and your
friends
what's important is whether or not you
are taking care of yourself
and thinking positive thoughts versus
negative thoughts
the world gave us a gigantic experiment
where we got to practice and get to
continue to practice
the most important skill in the planet
which is emotional
resilience the ability to face hard
and actually be okay the ability to face
the uncertain
and redirect your attention on things
that you
know that are certain rule number four
surround yourself with greatness as
is the case in life you're always going
to be growing
and when you hit new chapters in your
life
it's really important to be deliberate
and mindful
about the people that you spend time
with and who you surround yourself with
does that mean you gotta ditch your high
school friends absolutely not
but it might mean that you shouldn't
spend as much
time with them it might mean
that you should show up to those
friendships a little bit differently and
maybe they'll go a little bit deeper
and it definitely means that based on
where you are in your life right now
that you should get more proactive about
surrounding yourself with a group of
new friends or current friends that are
up to the same kind of growth that you
are
also if you want to have more self-love
confidence and motivation check out my
254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below you're
always going to need to push yourself
you're
always going to need to parent yourself
if you didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody
else thought
what's the thing you would love to be
doing with your life the prefrontal
cortex is the part of the brain that
you need in order to learn new behavior
in order to do something difficult
in order to do something uncertain in
order to do strategic thinking
rule number five disrupt the patterns
why do you think that is in human beings
that
you know things are going bad we won't
change
if they're going good we won't change
but it's almost like we need a massive
breakdown
near death experience divorce covid for
us to
see clearly to start changing well
there's a really simple answer
patterns so the thing about all human
beings
is that we are pattern learning machines
and if you feel stuck or broken
i guarantee you while you feel that way
you're not you have a pattern of
behavior or a pattern of thinking
that is broken and we
need to be disrupted
because we love our patterns and
even people that i know like i've heard
even when we're in pain we like pain's
familiar for a lot of people
yeah so a lot of people like you may be
listening to lewis and i talking and you
grew up in a super chaotic household
maybe your parents argued all the time
maybe your dad or mom were in and out
maybe there was a lot of fighting maybe
there was actual abuse i don't know what
was going on but it was chaotic as hell
and so as an adult you have vowed
yourself
you are not going to repeat that pattern
but what ends up happening
is because as a little kid you observed
witness absorbed the pattern of chaos in
your nervous system
unless you go about the intentional work
of breaking the pattern of chaos
you will create it in your own life
because it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do i keep
dating these why do i why do i go to
these bosses that treat me like crap
because you don't know what it feels
like
to be in a relationship with either a
boss or
a romantic partner or a roommate
that is consistent because for the first
18 years of your life you lived in an
estate called when's the next shoe gonna
drop
right and so wherever it is in your life
that something is broken there is a
pattern that you don't see yet
that is making you continue to stay in a
broken situation
rule number six lay one brick a day and
it's
all that thinking that overthinking that
thinking too
big thinking big is about dreams
thinking big is about goals thinking big
is about your heart and your soul and
figuring out what you want then once you
do that and you think big and you see
where you're headed
boom you got to come back and you've got
to go brick by
brick to make that vision stick you've
got to go brick by brick
to make the action stick you got to go
brick by brick
to lay that pathway forward and to keep
going
and let me tell you something i don't
care how busy you are i don't care how
tired you are i don't care how much
there is to do to make this big dream
forward
you have time to lay one brick a day you
really do
you really do and this is the secret
everybody
this is the secret to everything it's to
understanding that there is no timeline
to getting
your dreams done all there is to do is
to allow your heart and soul to dream
big
to see the path forward and then to pull
yourself into the moment
every day and have the discipline to be
deliberate
to lay one brick on that path that's it
and to keep reminding yourself
that everything that you're learning on
the way as you lie bricks down
and you move forward a little at a time
is helping you build the path
and there will be times that you start
to lay bricks in this direction and you
realize whoa wait a minute i'm going
over here and my dream is over there
i guess i better lay bricks over here
and head back in the direction then
you're gonna go this way
that's great because everything that you
learned over here
is going to be exactly what you needed
in order to be
doing what your big dream is rule number
seven make a change
having a breakdown is one of the biggest
things on the planet because what you
get
is you get a break from your own
[ __ ] and you can
look objectively at where you are
and for the first time look ahead and
say
well what do i want to go create and
nine times out of ten if you're
discouraged right now if you've
got financial devastation if you've if
you're facing something
that is making this moment in time as
hard for you as life was for lewis and i
in 2008 during the last recession
i beg you ask yourself honestly
if what you had is actually what you
wanted the thing that you just lost that
that job that you bitched about all the
time a relationship that was
bad to you yeah yes or the friends you
can't hang out with because
it's convenient and you can't you're in
court
like actually ask yourself if this is
what you wanted or were you just
used to it
being used to something lewis i think is
the biggest reason why people don't
change
i asked my mother i love my mother i
love my parents i've been married 51
years
which is a feat because they were my mom
was a teen mom but
uh i asked her once if she'd go to a
personal development seminar with me
what'd you say are you [ __ ] kidding
me
why would i want to change at my age wow
i might discover i hate my life
wow i was like okay i'm just gonna leave
that right there
rule number eight choose how you respond
and i always talk about how you have the
power in your life always i know that
you may have your feelings hurt i know
you may
be angry or upset or frustrated
i certainly feel those things all the
time in my life but i want you to
understand that no matter what's going
on
you always have the power because you
can choose what you think and what you
do next
you may not be able to control the way
that somebody treated you you may not be
able to control
uh the number of promotions that have
passed you by you may not be able to
control
whether or not your boss is a jerk face
or not to you
but you can choose how you respond to
these things and that's where your power
is
rule number nine get out of your head
this is
a very important first piece of advice
by the way is that a lot of times we
start to feel the weight of the
overwhelm
but we don't get out of our heads and if
you spend too much time
thinking about all the stuff that's
going on and you don't go through the
process
of breaking it down and figuring out
what actually is important to you
and prioritizing what you're going to do
about it
you're just going to continue to feel
heavier and heavier and heavier it's
more and more sunk i mean it's it's a
very
very difficult thing to feel and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is stop beating yourself up why don't
you like the size you are
is it okay because i don't believe in
losing weight
to be skinny i believe in getting
healthy
because of how it makes you feel yeah so
if you love the size that you
are and it's healthy you should stay the
size that you are
but if you look in the mirror
and seeing your body the size that it is
gives you evidence to say i'm a piece of
or i'm unworthy what do you say to
yourself when you see yourself in the
mirror
all of those things tell me what is it
let's get it out of your head
and let's bring it to the light because
you know you feel comfortable saying
this
to yourself when you're alone
don't you i want you to say it out loud
because it's
it's not okay to say this stuff to
yourself
what do you say to yourself that we're
not going to say anymore i'm disgusting
i'm disgusting what else
the way i look i hate the way that i
look i hate it i hate the way that i
feel
okay what do you want what do you
deserve
to feel good when they walk down the
street yes yes you do
see i think at the heart of this i think
at the heart of this is a belief
that you don't deserve to feel that way
so who taught you to feel that that you
don't deserve it when did you start
saying that to yourself that you don't
deserve it holly
maybe that's usually when it happens
so what i want you to do is i want you
to leave here and what you're going to
go to war against
is not your weight you're going to go to
war against the pattern in your head
okay because the longer you invalidate
yourself the less motivated you're going
to be to change
because you're beating yourself down so
we got to start with
not fixing you you're not broken
you're perfect how you are holly you are
i know you don't feel that way but i
feel that way yeah it's the pattern up
here
that's broken yeah so we just want you
to have a
zero tolerance policy for this like i'm
not worth it i don't deserve it i'm a
piece of
this um all that no five four three two
one it's like an axe
you got that and then you're going to
come up what can we say instead
i can do this i do that i can do this
but more important i think it needs to
be more heart-centered
i deserve to feel good
yeah i deserve to have what i want
watch me go get it now i've got a
special bonus clip from mel on how to
stop comparing yourself to others but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know
where do you need to stop beating
yourself up
let me know your answer put it down in
the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video you're still here
watching i want to celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you first of
all you're not in a race
so there's no catching up and i want you
to stop saying you need to catch up with
everybody right now whether you're
facing this issue at work because you
haven't been promoted
or you're facing this issue because
you're the only one of your girlfriends
who's not
engaged or married or pregnant or a mom
yet
or if you're facing this issue because
you feel like you look around
and you're comparing your life to
somebody else's stop that
stop that stop that stop that it is
one of the most horrible things that you
can do
because it's very demotivating because
what you're doing is you're making
yourself wrong for where you are
and that's not going to make you
motivated what i want you to do is see
the gap
and recognize that if you're jealous
it's because you want that thing
that's why
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there